This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Economic theory rests on a simple notion about human beings. People are rational. They seek out the best information. They measure costs and benefits, and maximize pleasure and profit. This idea of the rational economic actor has been around for centuries.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。经济学理论建立在一个关于人类的简单概念之上：人是理性的。他们寻求最佳信息，权衡成本与收益，并追求快乐和利润的最大化。这种理性经济人的观念已经存在了几个世纪。
actor has been around for centuries. But about 50 years ago, two obscure psychologists shattered these foundational assumptions. The psychologists showed that people routinely walk away from good money, and they explain why once people get in a hole, they often keep digging. The methods of these psychologists were as unusual as their insights. Daniel Kahneman and Amos Tversky spent hours together talking. They came up with playful thought experiments. They laughed a lot. We felt our own mistakes very funny. What was fun was finding yourself about to say something really stupid.
这种观念已经存在了几个世纪。但大约50年前，两位默默无闻的心理学家打破了这些基本假设。这两位心理学家证明，人们经常会放弃唾手可得的利益，并解释了为什么人们一旦陷入困境，往往会越陷越深。这两位心理学家的研究方法和他们的洞见一样不同寻常。丹尼尔·卡尼曼和阿莫斯·特沃斯基花了很多时间在一起交谈。他们想出了有趣的思维实验。他们经常大笑。我们觉得自己的错误非常滑稽。最有趣的是发现自己正要说出一些非常愚蠢的话。
This is Daniel Kahneman, the insights he developed with Amos Tversky who passed away in 1996 transformed the way we understand the mind. That transformation had philosophical implications. The stories about the past are so good that they create an illusion that life is understandable. And that's an illusion. And they create the illusion that you can predict the future. And that's an illusion. Professor Canaman, you're important insights. Daniel Kahneman won the Nobel Prize in Economics in 2002.
这位是丹尼尔·卡尼曼，他与1996年去世的阿莫斯·特沃斯基共同开发的洞见，改变了我们理解思维的方式。这种转变具有哲学意义。关于过去的故事是如此美好，以至于它们创造了一种生活是可以理解的错觉。那是一种错觉。它们还创造了一种你可以预测未来的错觉。那也是一种错觉。卡尼曼教授，您的洞见非常重要。丹尼尔·卡尼曼于2002年获得了诺贝尔经济学奖。
The new bridges between economics and psychology are attributed to your pioneering research. We've drawn extensively on research inspired by these two psychologists. So for Hidden Brain's 100th episode, I interviewed Nobel Prize-winning psychologist, Daniel Kahneman. We taped this interview before a live audience at NPR headquarters in Washington, D.C. Danny, welcome to Hidden Brain's 100th episode. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. So, Danny, as I was reading that introduction, I could almost see you cringing because you've spent a lifetime worried about overstatement and exaggeration and overconfidence and luck. And I'm wondering if we could just start there.
经济学与心理学之间的新桥梁归功于您的开创性研究。我们大量借鉴了受这两位心理学家启发的研究成果。因此，在《Hidden Brain》第100期节目中，我采访了诺贝尔奖得主、心理学家丹尼尔·卡尼曼。我们在华盛顿特区的NPR总部现场录制了这次采访。丹尼，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》第100期节目。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。那么，丹尼，当我读那段介绍时，我几乎可以看到你在畏缩，因为你一生都在担心夸大其词、过度自信和运气的问题。我想我们能不能从这里开始。
If you were to look back at your own life, how much of your success would you attribute to talent and how much to luck? I mean, you know, some talent was really needed. But luck, you know, I can see so many points in my life where luck made all the difference. And mainly the luck is with the people you need and the friendships you make. There is a large element of luck in that. And my life was transformed by sheer luck in finding a partner, an intellectual partner with whom we got along very well and we got a lot done. Before we get to Amos, I want to talk about another person whom you met.
如果你回顾自己的一生，你会将多少成功归功于天赋，多少归功于运气？我的意思是，你知道，确实需要一些天赋。但运气，你知道，我能看到我生命中许多关键时刻，运气起了决定性作用。主要是你遇到的人和结交的朋友带来的运气。这其中有很大的运气成分。而我的人生因为纯粹的运气而改变，那就是找到了一个合作伙伴，一个我们相处得非常好、共同完成了很多工作的知识伙伴。在谈到阿莫斯之前，我想谈谈你遇到的另一个人。
This was in 1941-42. You're a very young Jewish boy living in German-occupied Paris. And one day, you're out beyond curfew. An SS officer spots you and runs up to you. What happens next? Well, he doesn't run up to me, but he beckons me to him. And I was wearing a sweater. It was past the curfew, and my sweater had a yellow star on it,
那是在1941到1942年。你是一个住在德国占领区巴黎的犹太小男孩。有一天，你过了宵禁时间还在外面。一名党卫军军官发现了你，并向你跑来。接下来发生了什么？嗯，他没有向我跑来，但他招手让我过去。我当时穿着一件毛衣。已经过了宵禁时间，我的毛衣上缝着一颗黄星，
and so I was wearing it inside out. And he called me, and he picked me up. And I was really quite worried that he might see my yellow star. And he hugged me tight, and then he put me down, he opened his wallet, and he showed me a little boy. And then he gave me some money, and we went also for it was. Obviously, I reminded him of his son. And he wanted to hug his son, so he hugged me.
所以我把它反着穿。他叫我过去，把我抱了起来。我当时真的很担心他会看到我的黄星。但他紧紧地抱了我一下，然后把我放下，打开钱包，给我看了一个小男孩的照片。然后他给了我一些钱，我们就各自走开了。显然，我让他想起了他的儿子。他想拥抱他的儿子，所以他拥抱了我。
That's an experience. It was some reason, I mentioned it in my Nobel autobiography, but as illustrating a theme that was a theme in my family, actually, and my mother, especially, that people are very complicated. And that seemed to be an instance of something very complicated. And so it stayed that, you know, in that sense, it's a memory that was important to me. So when an event like that happens, I can imagine most people just saying,
那真是一次经历。出于某种原因，我在我的诺贝尔奖自传中提到了这件事，以此来说明我家庭中的一个主题，尤其是对我母亲而言，那就是人是非常复杂的。那似乎是一个非常复杂的事例。所以它一直留在那里，你知道，从这个意义上说，这是一个对我来说很重要的记忆。所以当这样的事情发生时，我可以想象大多数人只会说，
thank God, and moving on, but you found it interesting partly because you said there's something interesting that happened here. And from a very young age it seems you were drawn to these curiosities about how the mind worked. In some ways the SS officer was making a mistake. He was looking at you and drawing an association from you to sort to another child, maybe his own son. And of course in many ways it was an error. The mind was not working in a quote unquoteunquote rational fashion, but it was more associated. The complexity was that it's the combination of somebody who must have done some very evil things
谢天谢地，然后继续生活，但你觉得它很有趣，部分原因是你认为这里发生了一些有趣的事情。而且从很小的时候起，你似乎就被这些关于思维如何运作的好奇心所吸引。在某种程度上，那位党卫军军官犯了一个错误。他看着你，把你联想到了另一个孩子，也许是他自己的儿子。当然，在很多方面这是一个错误。思维并没有以所谓的“理性”方式运作，而是更多地基于联想。复杂之处在于，这是一个既做过非常邪恶的事情，
and have thought some very evil thoughts. And yet he was hugging me. And I mean, you know, that kind of complexity was everywhere. I mean, Hitler, you know, like children and like flowers and was very kind to some people. So we have a lot of difficulty putting that together with, you know, the things he did. But that complexity was always interesting. At what point do you feel you became the person
又想过非常邪恶念头的人，但他却拥抱了我。我的意思是，你知道，那种复杂性无处不在。我的意思是，希特勒，你知道，喜欢孩子和花，对某些人也非常友善。所以我们很难将这些与他所做的事情联系起来。但那种复杂性一直很有趣。你觉得你在什么时候成为了那个
who was paying attention to his own thoughts? Because so many of your early insights were developed obviously in experiments that you ran on people, but you were also observing the way your own mind worked and observing if you will oddities in the way that your own mind worked. Was that always the case with Danny Conneman? I think so.
关注自己思想的人？因为你的许多早期洞见显然是在你对他人进行的实验中得出的，但你也在观察自己思维的运作方式，并观察自己思维中所谓的怪癖。丹尼·卡尼曼一直都是这样吗？我想是的。
I mean, I wrote a psychological essay when I was 11. So it was short. But I'll tell you what the essay said, actually, because it shows quite a few things, I think. But so my older sister was taking exams at philosophy. And I had read some Pascal, and you know, Pascal explained why he gave proofs of God's existence. Pascal said that faith is God made sensible to the mind. And a little boy of 11, very pompous, of course, I said, how right. And then the psychological part was, I said, but this is very hard.
我的意思是，我在11岁时写过一篇心理学文章。虽然很短。但我可以告诉你那篇文章说了什么，因为它展示了很多东西，我想。我姐姐当时正在参加哲学考试。我读过一些帕斯卡的作品，你知道，帕斯卡解释了他为什么提供上帝存在的证明。帕斯卡说，信仰是上帝让心灵可感知的。而一个11岁的小男孩，当然非常自负，我说，说得太对了。然后心理学部分是，我说，但这非常困难。
The experience of faith is very rare. And so that's why we have churches and organs and pomp to sort of, and I called it, Erzats, I mean, sort of fake experience, to generate a fake experience. So that was, you know, that was psychology. And obviously, you know, that's what interested me then, and it's interested me since. Later on, as you were working as a professional psychologist now, you made in some ways a career of thinking about how your own mind worked. And I'm fascinated by this idea because in some ways,
信仰的体验非常罕见。这就是为什么我们有教堂、管风琴和排场，我称之为“替代品”，也就是某种虚假的体验，来产生一种虚假的体验。所以，你知道，那就是心理学。显然，你知道，那就是当时吸引我的东西，也是从那以后一直吸引我的东西。后来，当你作为一名专业心理学家工作时，你在某种程度上以思考自己思维的运作方式为职业。我对此非常着迷，因为在某种程度上，
a lot of people look at how their minds work and they're defensive about it, or they defend how their minds work, or they say, no, what I did was most made perfect sense. And instead in some ways, I think it, your humility, and clearly it's a temperamental quality of yours, helped you to sort of see some of these oddities and think about why they happen. That's not quite the way it happened, actually. I had my friend and collaborator, Emma said, we worked together on that, and nobody ever accused him of being humble.
很多人审视自己的思维方式时会采取防御态度，或者他们为自己的思维方式辩护，或者他们说，不，我所做的一切完全合情合理。相反，在某种程度上，我认为你的谦逊，显然这是你性格中的一种品质，帮助你看到了其中一些怪癖并思考它们发生的原因。其实事情并不是那样发生的。我和我的朋友兼合作者阿莫斯一起工作，没有人指责他谦逊。
He was not. But what the two of us did, we found our own mistakes very funny. And so we had a lot of fun, just exploring what is our first impulse when it's wrong. And that can be an endless source of fun. There was no particular humility on the contrary in a way. That is, we never thought that people were stupid because we were finding all of that in ourselves and we didn't think we were stupid. So there was very little humility there, but there was irony. And the irony was part of the
他并不谦逊。但我们两人所做的是，我们发现自己的错误非常滑稽。所以我们玩得很开心，只是探索当我们犯错时我们的第一冲动是什么。这可以成为无穷无尽的乐趣来源。这并没有什么特别的谦逊，相反，在某种程度上。也就是说，我们从不认为人们很愚蠢，因为我们在自己身上发现了所有这些，而我们并不认为自己很愚蠢。所以那里几乎没有什么谦逊，但有讽刺。而讽刺是其中的一部分。
funny. What was funny about it? I can see why it was interesting or why it was curious, but I understand that when you and I must work together, there was just endless amounts of hilarity. There was a lot of laughter. And you know, what was what was fun was finding yourself fun was finding yourself about to say something really stupid and you know having and sort of holding, holding back because you know better but it's that impulse to say things that you know that are without basis or that are purely associated and really it doesn't matter't matter how intelligent you are, or how educated you are. There are those intuitions,
有趣。关于它有什么有趣的？我明白为什么它很有趣或为什么它令人好奇，但我明白当你和阿莫斯一起工作时，总是有无穷无尽的欢笑。有很多笑声。你知道，有趣的是发现自己正要说出一些非常愚蠢的话，你知道，并且不得不克制住，因为你知道得更好，但那种冲动会让你说出你知道没有根据的，或者纯粹是联想的东西，真的，无论你有多聪明，或者受过多少教育，这都不重要。那些直觉，
or those thoughts that come from somewhere, that come very reliably and predictably, and that are wrong. So it's a big feel to study. Well, meaning Amos was clearly a stroke of luck. I mean, I don't think your life would have taken the same path that it did. Certainly not.
或者那些来自某处的想法，它们非常可靠且可预测地出现，而且是错误的。所以这是一个很大的研究领域。嗯，阿莫斯显然是运气使然。我的意思是，我不认为你的人生会走上同样的道路。当然不会。
I mean, you know, it's rare really, but he was exceptionally smart and very, very quick. And there is, when you have two people who are working together who really, in a way, love each other's mind and admire each other's mind. That is very special because it gives you a sort of confidence when the other, you say something and the other person sees something in it that you haven't seen. And this is very rare.
我的意思是，你知道，这真的很罕见，但他异常聪明，而且非常、非常敏捷。当你有两个真正合作的人，他们以某种方式热爱彼此的思想并钦佩彼此的思想时，这是非常特别的，因为它给了你一种信心，当对方说出一些你没有看到的东西时。这非常罕见。
That's this kind of mutual trust and looking for what's interesting and good in what the other person is saying. And both TNI, we were both quite critical people. I mean, he even more than I, but we made an exception for each other. And that was a joy. Psychologist Daniel Kahneman, Lane the Ground groundwork for what is today known as behavioral economics. In 2002, Daniel Kahneman was awarded the Nobel Prize in Economics. So many of your early insights were based
这就是那种相互信任，寻找对方所说内容中有趣和好的部分。我和阿莫斯，我们都是相当挑剔的人。我的意思是，他甚至比我更挑剔，但我们为彼此破了例。那是一种快乐。心理学家丹尼尔·卡尼曼为今天所知的行为经济学奠定了基础。2002年，丹尼尔·卡尼曼被授予诺贝尔经济学奖。所以你的许多早期洞见都是基于
on thought experiments where you came up with very simple questions that you posed to both yourselves and to other people. Why do these thought experiments? And when we talked a few days ago, you actually said that this is part of the reason you think that your work appealed to a larger audience, because even if the ideas were complex, the questions were inherently interesting and accessible.
思维实验，你提出了非常简单的问题，既问自己也问别人。为什么要进行这些思维实验？当我们几天前交谈时，你实际上说这是你认为你的工作吸引了更广泛受众的部分原因，因为即使想法很复杂，问题本身也很有趣且易于理解。
Well, that's a stroke of luck, really. In, there's a famous psychologist, Walter Michel, who wrote a book on the Marshmallows, a few years ago. And in 1964, he published his dissertation. And his dissertation was done in Jamaica with small children, and he asked those children two questions. And one of them was, there is a fairy who can make a view whatever you want to be, what you want to be.
嗯，那真是运气。有一位著名的心理学家沃尔特·米歇尔，几年前写了一本关于棉花糖的书。1964年，他发表了他的博士论文。他的论文是在牙买加对幼儿进行的，他问了那些孩子两个问题。其中一个是，有一位仙女可以让你成为任何你想成为的人，你想成为什么？
And the other question was, you can have this lollipop today, or two lollipops tomorrow, what do you prefer. Now, these two questions were correlated with everything inside. I mean, they were correlated with how bright the trial was, with how educated the parents were. And I just fell in love with that idea of the psychology of single questions. And I looked for ways to do that sort of thing. And the work with Amos on judgment turned out
另一个问题是，你可以今天得到这根棒棒糖，或者明天得到两根棒棒糖，你更喜欢哪一个？现在，这两个问题与内部的一切相关。我的意思是，它们与孩子的聪明程度、父母的受教育程度相关。我只是爱上了这种单一问题的心理学理念。我寻找方法来做那种事情。而与阿莫斯在判断力方面的合作证明
to lend itself to just that. That is, there is a single question that elicits a funny thought, and it makes a point. And you know, in the first place, we were very lucky in the choice of problem. There are just no other problems in psychology that lend themselves to that sort of thing, that you can involve the reader and present questions to the reader and you make the reader think. So you can do that in vision and everybody here I'm sure has had introductory psychology
非常适合这一点。也就是说，有一个单一的问题可以引出一个有趣的思考，并说明一个观点。而且你知道，首先，我们在选择问题上非常幸运。心理学中确实没有其他问题能像那样，你可以让读者参与进来，向读者提出问题，并让读者思考。所以你可以在视觉上做到这一点，我相信在座的每个人都上过心理学入门课，
at some point and there are those demonstrations of perceptual effects like figure ground or... Optical and perceptual... ...perceptual organization and so on. or the other round, or the process of reorganization, or... And they are on the page, and that's the phenomenon. You are your own subject. Now, you can do that on vision, you can do that on judgment, which is the field that we did it in. And that's it.
在某些时候，会有那些感知效果的演示，比如图形背景或……光学和感知…………感知组织等等。或者反过来，或者重组的过程，或者……它们就在书页上，这就是现象。你就是你自己的实验对象。现在，你可以在视觉上做到这一点，你可以在判断力上做到这一点，这是我们进行研究的领域。就是这样。
You can't do it on self-control, you can't do it on many other things, you can't do a personality study. So when I was talking of luck, that's luck to hit on something that, you know, we happen to be prepared for, and that is uniquely, lend itself uniquely to something that creates experiences in readers, you know, sheer luck. creates experiences in readers, you know, sheer luck. So after many, many years of collaboration together, your partnership with Amos founder, I think it's fair to say, I'm wondering whether you've given the same thought to why that happened, that you gave to other things that your mind does, and whether those insights,
你不能在自我控制上做到这一点，你不能在许多其他事情上做到这一点，你不能做人格研究。所以当我谈到运气时，那是运气使然，碰到了我们恰好准备好的东西，而且它独特地、独特地适合于创造读者体验的东西，你知道，纯粹的运气。创造读者体验，你知道，纯粹的运气。所以在多年合作之后，你与阿莫斯的伙伴关系结束了，我想说这是公平的，我想知道你是否像思考你的思维所做的其他事情一样，思考过为什么会发生这种情况，以及这些洞见，
I mean so many of your insights about how your mind has worked have helped the rest of us, is there anything here that could help the rest of us think about collaboration and partnership? No, I mean, you know, there's natural stresses in collaboration. The world is not kind to collaborations. You know, when you have two people who are reasonably talented and they work together and they overlap closely then I'm quoting Amos he said when I give a lecture people don't think I need anybody else to do the work and that was true to some extent of me as well and so
我的意思是，你关于思维如何运作的许多洞见都帮助了我们其他人，这里有什么可以帮助我们其他人思考合作和伙伴关系吗？不，我的意思是，你知道，合作中存在自然的压力。世界对合作并不友好。你知道，当你有两个相当有才华的人，他们一起工作并且重叠紧密时，我引用阿莫斯的话，他说当我在做讲座时，人们不认为我需要任何人来完成这项工作，在某种程度上我也一样，所以
that's creates stresses. And of course, I've given a lot of thought to it. We were fortunate that we went on as long as we did. We were fortunate that we remained friends, even when there were stresses in the collaboration. I remember research that Abraham Tesser did many years ago, where he looked at couples or other pairs of people who are very similar to one another.
这造成了压力。当然，我对此进行了很多思考。我们很幸运，我们合作了那么久。我们很幸运，即使在合作中有压力，我们仍然是朋友。我记得亚伯拉罕·泰瑟多年前所做的研究，他观察了非常相似的夫妇或其他配对的人。
And one of the things he found is, of course, the closer in similarity people were, the more they reached for the same goal. You had, let's say, a couple who are both writers, the success of one person tended to make the other person feel smaller. Even though you're happy for your partner, there's a part of you that says,
他发现的一件事是，当然，人们的相似度越接近，他们就越追求同一个目标。假设有一对夫妇都是作家，一个人的成功往往会让另一个人感到渺小。即使你为你的伴侣感到高兴，你内心的一部分也会说，
why can't I have the success that my partner has? And it's a very human thing of course. Yeah, of course. It's of course especially true if it's joined work, which the others. This is, there's really a dynamic. And I would say we were just about perfect for 10, 12 years, which is very long time. When we come back, what Danny and Amos discover together.
为什么我不能拥有我伴侣那样的成功？这当然是非常人性化的事情。是的，当然。如果是联合工作，那就更是如此。这确实是一种动态。我想说我们有10到12年几乎是完美的，这已经是很长的时间了。当我们回来时，丹尼和阿莫斯一起发现了什么。
Stay with us. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. For the 100th episode of our podcast, I interview Daniel Kahneman. He is the author of the book, Thinking, Fast and Slow. In the 1960s, Danny spent a summer with a group of eminent psychoanalysts at a treatment center in Massachusetts. The center had a routine. A patient was examined for a month by multiple experts, and then everyone came together to do a case study. They reviewed notes, they interviewed the patient together. One particular case left a strong impression
请继续收听。这是NPR。这是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在我们的播客第100期节目中，我采访了丹尼尔·卡尼曼。他是《思考，快与慢》一书的作者。20世纪60年代，丹尼在马萨诸塞州的一个治疗中心与一群杰出的精神分析学家度过了一个夏天。该中心有一个惯例。一名患者由多位专家检查一个月，然后大家聚在一起进行案例研究。他们审阅笔记，一起采访患者。一个特殊的案例留下了深刻的印象
on Danny. In the morning we learned that the young woman about whom we'd written the report had taken her life. And they did a very brave thing. They ran the case study, and I was deeply impressed, both by the honesty of what they did. But what they were trying to do, they were seeing signs that they had missed. And it was, you know, in retrospect, obviously, this was hindsight at work. I mean, now you know what's happened, so you're seeing signs and premonitions. And people are really feeling guilty. I saw her on the stairs and she looked strange and you know why didn't I stop to inquire. I mean you know
在丹尼心中。早上我们得知我们写过报告的那位年轻女子已经自杀了。他们做了一件非常勇敢的事情。他们进行了案例研究，我深受感动，既因为他们所做之事的诚实。但他们试图做的是，他们看到了他们错过的迹象。而且，你知道，回想起来，显然，这是事后诸葛亮。我的意思是，现在你知道发生了什么，所以你看到了迹象和预感。人们真的感到内疚。我在楼梯上看到她，她看起来很奇怪，你知道为什么我没有停下来询问。我的意思是，你知道
people look strange all the time. But you know when somebody so yeah that was that was an important episode. And of course what this episode reveals is how once an event happens, we trace back a story about how that event came to be. And of course, in journalism, we do this all the time. I remember after the 9-11 attacks, we spent years deconstructing all the errors that were made and drawing a pattern. When you see that pattern laid out, you have to say,
人们总是看起来很奇怪。但你知道，当某人……所以是的，那是一个重要的插曲。当然，这个插曲揭示了事件一旦发生，我们是如何追溯一个关于该事件如何发生的故事的。当然，在新闻业中，我们一直这样做。我记得在9/11袭击之后，我们花了几年时间解构所有犯下的错误并找出模式。当你看到那个模式呈现出来时，你不得不说，
well, those people must have been really dumb because it's so obvious that there was a pattern that led to the 9-11 attacks. Yeah, this is hindsight, and it's one of the most important phenomena, truly in psychology and the psychology of judgment, because you understand the past, and the past surprises stop being surprising at the moment they happen, you know, then you have a story and you shouldn't have been surprised. And when you reconstruct it, you also reconstruct wrongly what you believed at the time. So you minimize, you reduce the surprise. So not only was it inevitable, but also I almost, I really sensed it. So, you know, now where this goes really wrong and is that the story is about the past or so good, that they create an illusion that life is understandable.
嗯，那些人一定真的很笨，因为很明显有一个模式导致了9/11袭击。是的，这是事后诸葛亮，它是心理学和判断力心理学中真正最重要的现象之一，因为你理解了过去，过去的惊喜在发生的那一刻就不再令人惊讶了，你知道，然后你就有了一个故事，你不应该感到惊讶。当你重构它时，你也错误地重构了你当时所相信的东西。所以你最小化了，你减少了惊喜。所以它不仅是不可避免的，而且我也几乎，我真的感觉到了。所以，你知道，现在这在什么地方真正出了问题，那就是关于过去的故事是如此美好，以至于它们创造了一种生活是可以理解的错觉。
And that's an illusion. And that they create the illusion that you can predict the future, and that's an illusion. And it's maintained by hand side. So hand side is a central phenomenon really. And of course the errors we make eventually led to prospect theory, which was the work which you were cited for in the Nobel Prize among other things. If you were to explain prospect theory to an eighth grader, is there a way to do that? Well, it's very easy to explain.
那是一种错觉。它们创造了一种你可以预测未来的错觉，那是一种错觉。它是由事后诸葛亮维持的。所以事后诸葛亮确实是一个核心现象。当然，我们犯的错误最终导致了前景理论，这是你获得诺贝尔奖所引用的工作，除其他事项外。如果你要向八年级学生解释前景理论，有什么方法吗？嗯，解释起来很容易。
It's much harder to make it interesting. And the theory that dominated thinking, when we wrote, and to a very large extent, still dominates economic thinking. It was formulated first in 1738, so it's been around a long time. And what it says is that when you're looking at a gamble, what you're evaluating, is you're evaluating two states of wealth. Your wealth, if you will win, and your wealth, if you will lose, and then if
让它变得有趣要难得多。在我们写作时主导思维的理论，在很大程度上仍然主导着经济思维。它最早是在1738年制定的，所以它已经存在很长时间了。它所说的是，当你面对一场赌博时，你所评估的是两种财富状态。你赢了之后的财富，和你输了之后的财富，然后如果
you are offered a sure thing, instead of your wealth, if you get that true thing. And for 200 and you know, 60 years and so, people accepted that theory. Now, the theory really is, doesn't make sense, if you stop to think about it. People don't think of gains and losses as states of wealth. They just don't. They think of gains and losses as gains and losses. That was the fundamental insight of Prospect Theory. So, you know, you could ask that, you know, you get a Nobel Prize for that.
你被提供了一个确定的东西，而不是你的财富，如果你得到那个确定的东西。260年来，人们接受了那个理论。现在，如果你停下来思考一下，这个理论确实说不通。人们并不把收益和损失视为财富状态。他们根本不这样想。他们把收益和损失视为收益和损失。这就是前景理论的基本洞见。所以，你知道，你可以问，你知道，你为此获得了诺贝尔奖。
And you do in a certain context because if it surprises people. One of the things you say in the book is, are comforting conviction that the world makes sense, rests on a secure foundation, are almost unlimited ability to ignore our ignorance. And of course, you've made, spent a lifetime exploring the depths of your ignorance and all of our ignorance. But in many ways, there's something deeply human about this. To see the world as being chaotic and unpredictable and noisy is fundamentally unsettling. And it's easier to see the world as understandable and comprehensible and that fits in a story. Well, it's not, you know, we really have no option. I mean, the mind is created to make sense of
而且你在某种背景下确实会获得，因为它让人们感到惊讶。你在书中说的一件事是，我们关于世界是有意义的令人欣慰的信念，建立在一个坚实的基础上，即我们几乎无限的忽视我们无知的能力。当然，你花了一辈子探索你无知的深度以及我们所有人的无知。但在很多方面，这其中有一些非常人性化的东西。将世界视为混乱、不可预测和嘈杂是根本令人不安的。将世界视为可理解和可理解的，并符合一个故事，这更容易。嗯，这不是，你知道，我们真的没有选择。我的意思是，思维被创造出来是为了理解
things. I mean, vision makes sense of things. We see objects. We see objects moving. And it's the same with judgment and thinking. We have to make sense of things. And we can't do otherwise. So it's not, you know, that we would be unsettled if we did otherwise. We can't. We make sense of things and we can't do otherwise. So it's not that we would be unsettled if we did otherwise. We can't. We make sense of things. That's the fun. We're since making organisms. And of course, it's worth pointing out that even though this leads to errors,
事物。我的意思是，视觉理解事物。我们看到物体。我们看到物体在移动。判断和思考也是如此。我们必须理解事物。我们别无选择。所以这不是，你知道，如果我们不这样做，我们会感到不安。我们不能。我们理解事物，我们别无选择。所以这不是如果我们不这样做，我们会感到不安。我们不能。我们理解事物。这就是乐趣。我们是意义制造的有机体。当然，值得指出的是，即使这导致了错误，
it's also the case that much of the time, this is enormously valuable, and our sense-making ability is actually works great, that it actually allows us to navigate the world successfully. Of course, I mean, you know, we're right, almost all the time. I mean, you know, we couldn't survive if we were and tried almost all the time. We make interesting mistakes,
这也是事实，在很多时候，这是非常有价值的，我们的意义制造能力实际上运作得很好，它实际上使我们能够成功地驾驭世界。当然，我的意思是，你知道，我们几乎一直都是对的。我的意思是，你知道，如果我们一直都是错的，我们就无法生存。我们犯了有趣的错误，
and sometimes they're important mistakes, but mostly we're very well adapted to our environment. So when you think about news events, if I tell you, there are 19 hijackers who have flown planes into major buildings. And then we go back and we get biographical sketches of these people, and we understand their ideologies. And it activates things in our minds,
有时它们是重要的错误，但大多数时候我们非常适应我们的环境。所以当你想到新闻事件时，如果我告诉你，有19名劫机者驾驶飞机撞向主要建筑物。然后我们回去，我们得到这些人的传记草图，我们理解他们的意识形态。它激活了我们心中的东西，
because of course, there are these agents that are doing these things to us. And we then spend hundreds of billions of dollars trying to combat terrorism. And you say, OK, that makes sense. This is a major threat. We've dealt with it. But let's say you have another threat over here,
因为当然，有这些代理人正在对我们做这些事情。然后我们花费数千亿美元试图打击恐怖主义。你说，好的，这说得通。这是一个重大威胁。我们已经处理了它。但假设你有另一个威胁在这里，
where I tell you that in 80 years or 100 years, the temperature might rise five degrees. And as a result of this, the oceans might warm a little bit, and sea levels might rise by two or three inches. And as a result of this, the models predict that climate events will become more serious, at least according to the models, but you have to understand probability. And in order to try and head that off, you actually have to take very painful steps right now, maybe driving your car less, maybe living in a smaller house,
我告诉你，在80年或100年后，温度可能会上升5度。结果，海洋可能会稍微变暖，海平面可能会上升两三英寸。结果，模型预测气候事件将变得更加严重，至少根据模型是这样，但你必须理解概率。为了试图阻止这一点，你实际上现在必须采取非常痛苦的步骤，也许少开车，也许住在一个更小的房子里，
all kinds of things that are painful in the here and now for something that seems difficult, often the distance, and requires you to really understand statistics and probability. You've actually called climate change in some way sort of a perfect storm of the ways in which our minds are not equipped to deal with certain kinds of threats. I mean, it's really, if you were to design a problem that of the ways in which our minds are not equipped to deal with certain kinds of threats.
所有这些在此时此地都是痛苦的事情，为了一个看起来困难、遥远的事情，并且需要你真正理解统计学和概率。你实际上在某种程度上称气候变化为我们思维无法应对某些威胁方式的完美风暴。我的意思是，真的，如果你要设计一个问题，关于我们思维无法应对某些威胁的方式。
I mean, it's really, if you were to design a problem that the mind is not equipped to deal with, you know, climate change would fit the bill. It's distance, it's abstract, it's contested. And it doesn't take much. If it's contested, it's 50-50, you know, for many people immediately. You know, you don't ask, what do most scientists do, which side are the national academy of sciences? That's not the way it works. You know, some people say this, other people say that, and if I don't want to believe in it, I don't have to believe in it. So, it's, I'm
我的意思是，真的，如果你要设计一个思维无法应对的问题，你知道，气候变化会符合要求。它是遥远的，它是抽象的，它是受争议的。而且不需要太多。如果它是有争议的，那是50-50，你知道，对许多人来说立即就是这样。你知道，你不会问，大多数科学家做什么，国家科学院站在哪一边？这不是它的运作方式。你知道，有些人这么说，其他人那么说，如果我不想相信它，我就不必相信它。所以，它是，我
really, well, I'm pessimistic in general, but I'm, but I'm, I'm pessimistic in general, but I'm pessimistic in particular about the ability of democracies to deal with a threat like that effectively. If there were a comet hurtling down toward us, an event that would be predictable with the day, we'd mobilize. So it's not even that it's distant in time. If it was going to affect our children, we'd mobilize. But this is too abstract, possible, it's very different. We're not doing it in fact. So besides being pessimistic, does your research and understanding of this phenomenon give you any insight into how we should maybe talk about climate change and what we can do? Well, I think scientists, in a way, are deluded in that they have the idea that there is
真的，嗯，我总体上是悲观的，但我，但我，我总体上是悲观的，但我特别悲观的是民主国家有效应对这种威胁的能力。如果有一颗彗星向我们冲来，一个可以在某一天预测的事件，我们会动员起来。所以它甚至不是因为它在时间上很遥远。如果它会影响我们的孩子，我们会动员起来。但这太抽象了，可能的，它非常不同。事实上我们没有这样做。所以除了悲观之外，你对这种现象的研究和理解是否让你对我们应该如何谈论气候变化以及我们可以做什么有任何洞见？嗯，我认为科学家在某种程度上被误导了，因为他们认为有一种
one way of knowing things, and you know things when you have evidence for them. But that's simply not the case. People who have religious beliefs or strong political beliefs, they know things without having compelling evidence for them. And so there is a possibility of knowing things, which is clearly determined socially. I mean, we have our religion and our politics and so on because we love or used to love and trust the people who held those beliefs. There is no other way to explain why people hold to one religion and think other religions are funny, you know, which is really a very common observation. So the only way would be to create social pressure. So for me, it would be a milestone if you manage to take influential evangelists,
了解事物的方法，你知道，当你有了证据时，你就知道了事物。但事实并非如此。有宗教信仰或强烈政治信仰的人，他们在没有令人信服的证据的情况下就知道事物。所以有一种了解事物的可能性，这显然是社会决定的。我的意思是，我们有我们的宗教和政治等等，因为我们爱或曾经爱并信任那些持有这些信仰的人。没有其他方法可以解释为什么人们坚持一种宗教而认为其他宗教很有趣，你知道，这确实是一个非常普遍的观察。所以唯一的方法是制造社会压力。所以对我来说，如果你能让有影响力的福音派传教士，
preachers, to adopt the idea of global warming and to preach it. That would change things. It's not going to happen by presenting more evidence that I think is clear. When we come back, we'll talk about happiness, memory, and noise. Stay with us. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantantham. Daniel Kahneman won the Nobel Prize for a series of ideas that helped develop the field of behavioral economics.
牧师，采纳全球变暖的观点并宣扬它，那将是一个里程碑。那会改变事情。仅仅通过提供我认为很清楚的更多证据是不会发生的。当我们回来时，我们将谈论幸福、记忆和噪音。请继续收听。这是NPR。这是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。丹尼尔·卡尼曼因一系列有助于发展行为经济学领域的想法而获得了诺贝尔奖。
Danny, I don't know how you got an ethics panel to approve the study, but it's one of my favorite studies of all time. Tell me about the colonoscopy study and the Puykenhoulos. Well, the colonoscopy study was devised to test an idea that when people form a memory of an episode or an impression of an episode that had a certain duration, that actually they completely neglect the duration. And what they're sensitive to are illustrative, or crucial moments, and in particular, when it's a painful experience, it's the peak of the pain and it's the end of the pain. It's so much that pain you're at in the end. So that was a theory for which we had other evidence. And my friend, Donald Vredumair, who
丹尼，我不知道你是怎么让伦理委员会批准这项研究的，但它是我有史以来最喜欢的实验之一。告诉我关于结肠镜检查研究和……嗯，结肠镜检查研究旨在测试一个想法，即当人们形成对某段经历的记忆或对具有一定持续时间的经历的印象时，实际上他们完全忽略了持续时间。而他们敏感的是说明性的或关键的时刻，特别是当它是一种痛苦的经历时，它是痛苦的顶峰和痛苦的结束。这就是你在最后承受的痛苦。所以这是一个我们有其他证据支持的理论。我的朋友，多伦多的一位医生唐纳德·雷德迈尔，他
is a physician in Toronto, he volunteered to create a study around that. So a study was run on people at the colonoscopy, which, at the time, was very painful. I mean, for those of you who have not reached the age of colonoscopy, which at the time was very painful. I mean, for those of you who have not reached the age of colonoscopy, it won't be painful when you have it. But at that time, it really was. So people had a colonoscopy.
自愿围绕它进行了一项研究。所以对结肠镜检查的人进行了一项研究，这在当时是非常痛苦的。我的意思是，对于那些还没有达到结肠镜检查年龄的人，这在当时是非常痛苦的。我的意思是，对于那些还没有达到结肠镜检查年龄的人，当你做的时候它不会很痛苦。但在当时，它确实很痛苦。所以人们做了结肠镜检查。
And then half of them, it ended when it ended. But for half of them, they left the tube in for another minute or so. Now, this is not pleasant. Nobody would volunteer to have the tube in for another minute. But it improves the memory very significantly, because it's less painful than what went on before. It's not desirable, you wouldn't choose it, but it makes a difference between a really aversive memory, which you have when they pull the tube at a moment of high pain, the whole thing is very bad. But if you end on a gentler note, even if it's still painful, the memory improves.
然后他们中有一半，它结束时就结束了。但对于另一半，他们把管子多留了一分钟左右。现在，这并不愉快。没有人会自愿让管子多留一分钟。但它非常显著地改善了记忆，因为它比之前发生的事情痛苦要小。这不是理想的，你不会选择它，但它在真正令人厌恶的记忆之间产生了差异，当你把管子拔出来时，在剧烈疼痛的时刻，整个事情都很糟糕。但如果你以更温和的方式结束，即使它仍然很痛苦，记忆也会改善。
Memory wasn't designed to measure ongoing happiness or to measure total suffering. For survival, you really don't need to put a lot of weight on duration, on the duration of experiences. It's how bad they are and whether they end well. I mean, that is really the information that you need for an organism. And so, they're very good evolutionary reasons for the peak and end rule and for the neglect of duration. It leads to, in some cases, to absurd results.
记忆并不是为了衡量持续的幸福或衡量总的痛苦而设计的。为了生存，你真的不需要在持续时间、经历的持续时间上投入太多权重。重要的是它们有多糟糕以及它们是否以好的方式结束。我的意思是，这确实是一个有机体所需要的信息。所以，对于峰终定律和对持续时间的忽视，有非常好的进化原因。它在某些情况下导致了荒谬的结果。
But... So, if you are a policy maker, I feel like this is a real ethical dilemma. So, if you are a policy maker, I feel like this is a real ethical dilemma. So let's say, for example, I'm running a hospital. I think the colonoscopy study or versions of it have later found that if you actually give people the painful experience
但是……所以，如果你是一名政策制定者，我觉得这是一个真正的伦理困境。所以，如果你是一名政策制定者，我觉得这是一个真正的伦理困境。所以，举个例子，我经营一家医院。我认为结肠镜检查研究或其版本后来发现，如果你实际上给人们痛苦的经历
followed by the less painful experience, they are more likely to come back for the next colonoscopy because their memory of the colonoscopy was less painful. So you could argue from a public policy standpoint, where you want people to get tested, the right thing to do is to extend their pain in order that they will remember the pain as being less and come back more often. However, also from an ethical point of view,
随后是痛苦较小的经历，他们更有可能回来进行下一次结肠镜检查，因为他们对结肠镜检查的记忆痛苦较小。所以你可以从公共政策的角度争辩，你希望人们接受检查，正确的事情是延长他们的痛苦，以便他们会记住痛苦较小并更频繁地回来。然而，从伦理的角度来看，
you could argue that subjecting people to more pain than you need to subject them to is unethical. So what should we do? That's what it's easy. I mean, there are harder versions of it. But that one is easy because you would never frame it that way. You would just tell the people who are doing the procedure. Be very gentle at the end.
你也可以争辩说，让人们承受比你需要让他们承受的更多的痛苦是不道德的。那么我们该怎么办？这很容易。我的意思是，有更难的版本。但那个很容易，因为你永远不会那样表述它。你只会告诉那些进行手术的人。最后要非常温柔。
Be slow and gentle at the end. And that sounds like a good thing. And it's good for policy, and it will get more people. It will leave better memories, it will more compliance and so on. So there are ways, sometimes, of not presenting quite as sharply as you did. What would be a more difficult ethical dilemma
最后要缓慢而温柔。这听起来是一件好事。这对政策有好处，它会吸引更多的人。它会留下更好的记忆，它会有更多的合规性等等。所以，有时有办法不表现得像你那样尖锐。什么会是一个更困难的伦理困境
that I didn't think of that you could place to your, apply to yourself? Well, I think that if real suffering is involved, somebody in pain, and say, you can be in pain and barely conscious, or you can be in pain, and they will eliminate the memory at the end. So what is the, how much weight should you give to pain that the patient might be screaming but will not remember?
我没有想到，你可以对自己提出的？嗯，我认为如果涉及真正的痛苦，某人处于痛苦中，并且说，你可以处于痛苦中且几乎没有意识，或者你可以处于痛苦中，他们会在最后消除记忆。所以什么是，你应该给病人可能在尖叫但不会记住的痛苦多少权重？
You know, that's an ethical dilemma. And of course, this does have all kinds of other implications. You've done some work looking at, you know, if you could go on a vacation, but you couldn't take photographs on the vacation, how would you think about a vacation? In other words, you're, you essentially have these two models of how the mind works. There's a mind that experiences life, and there's a mind that remembers life, and these two minds don't always agree with one another. Well, I mean, they have different interests, you know, why? So I spoke of the experiencing self, which is, you know, the one that lives moment to moment. And the remembering self is the one that keeps score. And the scores
你知道，那是一个伦理困境。当然，这确实有各种其他影响。你做了一些研究，观察，你知道，如果你可以去度假，但你不能在度假时拍照，你会如何看待度假？换句话说，你，你本质上拥有这两种关于思维如何运作的模型。有一个体验生活的思维，有一个记忆生活的思维，而这两个思维并不总是彼此同意。嗯，我的意思是，它们有不同的兴趣，你知道，为什么？所以我谈到了体验自我，也就是，你知道，那个时刻生活的人。而记忆自我就是那个记分的人。而分数
that are generated, are generated by rules such as the peak end rule and so on. And so sometimes you can see that experiences are very different duration, and how do they matter? Oh, what is the value that you should attach to an experience that you will not remember, or that somebody will not remember? So my question on, in that context, was, I mean, consider your plans for your next occasion. And now imagine that at the end of the vacation, they will destroy all your pictures, and they'll give you an amnesic drug so that you won't remember a thing.
产生的，是由诸如峰终定律等规则产生的。所以有时你可以看到经历是非常不同的持续时间，它们有什么关系？哦，你应该给一个你不会记住的经历，或者某人不会记住的经历赋予什么价值？所以我在那种背景下的问题是，我的意思是，考虑你下一次度假的计划。现在想象一下，在度假结束时，他们会销毁你所有的照片，他们会给你一种健忘症药物，这样你就什么都不会记得了。
Now would you change your vacation plans if you knew that? And many people would, actually, because I think many people go on vacations to create memories for future consumption, which doesn't always happen. I mean, in my case, never happens. I never look in pictures, but that's a dilemma. So you conducted a study I remember a few years ago. I think it was published in the Journal of Science, where you evaluated how happy parents felt as they went through their days. And there's two ways you can, of course, ask the question. You can ask parents how happy are you with parenting?
那么，如果你知道这一点，你会改变你的度假计划吗？事实上，很多人会，因为我认为很多人去度假是为了创造未来可以回味的记忆，但这并不总是会发生。我的意思是，就我而言，从来没发生过。我从不看照片，但这确实是个两难的问题。我记得几年前你做过一项研究，好像发表在《科学》杂志上，你评估了父母在日常生活中感到有多快乐。当然，你可以用两种方式来问这个问题。你可以问父母：你对为人父母感到快乐吗？
And many parents will say it's the best thing they ever did. But then you can also ask parents on a moment-to-moment basis as they're parenting how they feel, and the answer turns out somewhat differently. Well, yeah, I mean, it turns out that parenting, if you really take the experiencing view of it, then it's like washing dishes, maybe a little worse, often, and then it has its moments. And it's the peak moments that people remember.
很多父母会说这是他们做过的最好的事情。但你也可以在父母履行职责时，逐个时刻地询问他们的感受，结果答案却大不相同。嗯，是的，我的意思是，事实证明，如果你真的从体验的角度来看，为人父母就像洗碗一样，甚至可能更糟，当然也有它的高光时刻。而人们记住的正是这些高光时刻。
And when people remember the's moments, and it's the peak moments that people remember. And when people remember the peak moments, it makes the whole thing worthwhile, so it changes the meaning of the whole experience. So that was a much contestant finding, very unpopular finding, but very strong finding. If you look at experiences, people have more fun with their friends than with their spouses, you know, quite a bit. And if you were trying to make to increase the happiness of the experiencing
当人们记住这些时刻时，正是这些高光时刻让人们铭记。当人们记住这些高光时刻时，它让整件事变得物有所值，从而改变了整个体验的意义。所以那是一个备受争议的发现，非常不受欢迎，但非常有力的发现。如果你观察人们的体验，你会发现人们和朋友在一起比和配偶在一起时更开心，你知道，多得多。如果你试图去增加体验者的快乐，
self, you would do very different things than people do because what people typically do, if they try to satisfy their remembering self. And maximizing the happiness of your experiencing self would make you more social, less ambitious. It would make you spend a lot more time with people that you love or like or enjoy because it's very largely social. So there are important implications of that distinction. Is there any insight that someone can draw from this work about whether they should become a parent, given this discrepancy between the remembering self and experiencing self? And I should remind you before you answer that your daughter is in the audience here with us. I have never met, almost never met, people who regretted having had their children.
你会做与人们通常所做的非常不同的事情，因为人们通常做的是试图满足他们的记忆自我。而最大化体验自我的快乐会让你变得更善于社交，更少野心。它会让你花更多时间与你爱、喜欢或享受的人在一起，因为这很大程度上是社交性的。所以这种区分有重要的意义。鉴于记忆自我和体验自我之间的这种差异，关于是否应该成为父母，人们能从这项工作中得出什么见解吗？在你回答之前，我应该提醒你，你的女儿就在观众席中。我从来没见过，几乎没见过后悔生孩子的人。
So if you measure things by the remembering self and that's the only way, the point is that the experiencing self doesn't make decisions. All the decisions are made by the remembering self and the remembering self never regrets having had children. So from that point of view, the answer is clear. Psychologist Daniel Kahneman, laying the groundwork for what is today known as behavioral economics.
所以如果你用记忆自我来衡量事物，而且这是唯一的方法，重点是体验自我不会做决定。所有的决定都是由记忆自我做出的，而记忆自我从不后悔生过孩子。所以从这个角度来看，答案很明确。心理学家丹尼尔·卡尼曼，为今天被称为行为经济学的领域奠定了基础。
Danny explained many of these insights in his 2011 book, Thinking Fast and Slow. You're working on a new book where the couple of other people, but it's also a new area that you're looking at. A lot of the earlier work looked at the issue of biases and errors, and there's a new focus for a lot of the work that you're looking at, a lot of the earlier work looked at the issue of biases and errors, and there's a new focus for a lot of the work that you're doing right now, and it has to
丹尼在他2011年的书《思考，快与慢》中解释了许多这些见解。你正在和另外几个人写一本新书，但这也是你正在研究的一个新领域。早期的很多工作关注的是偏见和错误的问题，而你现在正在做的很多工作有一个新的重点，它与
do with the question of noise. What does that mean? Well, there are really two kinds of, to broad families of error. There is bias, and there is noise. And noise simply means randomness. It's variability that shouldn't be there. So if you imagine target shooting, then where the cluster of shots is,
噪音的问题有关。那是什么意思？嗯，实际上有两种广泛的错误类别。一种是偏见，另一种是噪音。噪音仅仅意味着随机性。它是本不应该存在的变异性。所以如果你想象射击目标，那么射击群所在的位置，
there could be far from the target that's bias, but the variability of the cluster, that's noise. Many people, and certainly I in the past, are very interested in biases, and we think in terms of biases much more than we did like 60 years ago, where people would think of random error. And I now think that we have exaggerated biases, and that most areas are really noise, their randomness, and it's a very different approach to error than focusing on biases. I mean, I don't want to overstate it, biases are very important and so on, but noise has
可能远离目标，那是偏见，但射击群的变异性，那就是噪音。许多人，当然包括过去的我，对偏见非常感兴趣，我们思考偏见的方式比60年前多得多，那时人们会想到随机误差。我现在认为我们夸大了偏见，大多数错误实际上是噪音，是随机性，这与关注偏见相比是一种非常不同的处理错误的方法。我的意思是，我不想夸大其词，偏见非常重要等等，但噪音
been neglected, and I think it deserves attention. Do you think it has implications that are different from the implications related to bias when it comes to public policy, for example, is it easier to reduce the effects of noise to address them than bias? Well, certainly. I mean, you can, in the first place, if you take judgment away and have a computer
一直被忽视，我认为它值得关注。你认为它在公共政策方面是否具有与偏见相关的不同含义？例如，减少噪音的影响是否比解决偏见更容易？嗯，当然。我的意思是，首先，如果你取消判断，让计算机
makes the decision, the computer will be noise-free. Algorithms are noise-free. In the sense that you present the same problem twice, you'll get the same answer. Whereas if you present the same problem to different judges or to the same judge at different times of day, you're going to get different answers. So you can eliminate noise by algorithm.
做出决定，计算机将是无噪音的。算法是无噪音的。意思是如果你把同一个问题呈现两次，你会得到相同的答案。而如果你把同一个问题呈现给不同的法官，或者在一天中的不同时间呈现给同一个法官，你会得到不同的答案。所以你可以通过算法消除噪音。
And I think we should do that wherever we can. And where we can't do that, we should, I think, the implication is that we should try to structure the judgment process, so as to make it more reliable. I'll give you an example where this really matters. There is a thing in the United States that people call the asylum lottery because people who ask for asylum get a judge, they get the judge at random. And in some cases they have an 80% chance of getting through and in other cases 15, that's noise.
我认为我们应该尽可能这样做。而在我们无法做到这一点的地方，我认为其含义是我们应该尝试构建判断过程，使其更加可靠。我给你举一个这真的很重要的例子。在美国有一件事人们称之为庇护彩票，因为申请庇护的人会随机分配到一名法官。在某些情况下，他们有80%的机会通过，而在其他情况下只有15%，这就是噪音。
And you really don't want it, I think. We're in the process right now at Hidden Brain of hiring someone. And in fact, we just conducted two interviews today and we have a couple tomorrow. And as I was doing the interviews, I was thinking about some of the work that you've done. In some ways, this is your earliest work,
而且我认为你真的不希望这样。我们目前正在Hidden Brain招聘人员。事实上，我们今天刚进行了两次面试，明天还有几次。当我在进行面试时，我一直在思考你做过的一些工作。在某些方面，这是你最早的工作，
going back many, many decades, looking at how you can reduce errors in the interview process. And I don't know whether you think of it as bias or you think about it as noise. But either way, it leads to flawed outcomes. And you came up with a technique that could address it. Yeah, I actually did come up with a technique a little more than 62 years ago, actually.
追溯到几十年前，研究如何减少面试过程中的错误。我不知道你是把它看作偏见还是噪音。但无论哪种方式，它都会导致有缺陷的结果。而你提出了一种可以解决它的技术。是的，我确实在62年前多一点的时候提出了一种技术。
I was an officer in the Israeli Army. It was 1954. The Israeli Army was very young. It was 1956, actually. And I set up an interview system, which is a template for a lot of what is going on, and is a certainly a template for the way I think decisions should be made.
我当时是以色列军队的一名军官。那是1954年。以色列军队还很年轻。实际上是1956年。我建立了一个面试系统，它是很多正在进行的事情的模板，当然也是我思考决策方式的模板。
I haven't thought of that for many years. And the template is you have a problem. You need to evaluate people, break it up into dimensions. You know, what sounds elementary and I'm not going to say anything very surprising. Make judgments of each dimension independently of all the others. That independence is essential. Don't form a general impression until you have all the information. Delay intuition. Don't give it up necessarily.
我已经很多年没想过那个了。模板是你有一个问题。你需要评估人，将其分解为维度。你知道，这听起来很基础，我不会说任何非常令人惊讶的事情。独立于所有其他维度对每个维度做出判断。这种独立性至关重要。在获得所有信息之前，不要形成总体印象。推迟直觉。不一定要放弃它。
Delay it. And the results are just better when you do things that way. And I think that's probably very general, as a way of thinking about judgment and decision making. It's a way of reducing noise, of increasing reliability. And it's not very costly, and I'd like to promote it. So of course, the idea, if I understand correctly, is you score people on different criteria,
推迟它。当你这样做时，结果会更好。我认为这作为一种思考判断和决策的方式可能非常普遍。这是一种减少噪音、提高可靠性的方法。而且成本不高，我想推广它。所以当然，如果我理解正确的话，这个想法是你根据不同的标准给人们评分，
give them a ranking so that you're evaluating it. But there's also an interesting piece of advice, which I understand they still offer in the Israeli Army when they're doing these evaluations. The final piece of advice after you understand they still offer in the Israeli army when they are doing these evaluations. The final piece of advice after you've done the calculations. What is that advice? Yeah, well that's, so I set up that interviewing system. I was 22 years old.
给他们一个排名，这样你就在评估它。但还有一个有趣的建议，据我了解，他们在以色列军队进行这些评估时仍然提供这个建议。最后的建议是在你理解他们仍然在以色列军队进行这些评估时提供。最后的建议是在你完成计算之后。那是什么建议？是的，嗯，那是，所以我建立了那个面试系统。我当时22岁。
And the people, the interviewers who were 19 years old, they really didn't like that suggestion. What they really wanted was to have a heart-to-heart conversation and then to form a general impression of how good the combat soldier that individual would be. But they said, you are turning us into robots. And they had a point. And then I told them, OK, I'll compromise. You do it my way, the interview. You run the whole interview just
而那些19岁的面试官，他们真的不喜欢那个建议。他们真正想要的是进行一次交心的谈话，然后对那个人作为战斗士兵会有多出色形成一个总体印象。但他们说，你把我们变成了机器人。他们说得有道理。然后我告诉他们，好吧，我妥协。你按我的方式做，面试。你进行整个面试，只是
and you generate those scores independently, fact-based, and so on. Don't think of anything until the end. And in the end, close your eyes and give a score. How good a soldier will that person be? Now much to my surprise, that intuitive score is really very good. I mean, it says good as the average of the six trades.
并且独立地生成那些分数，基于事实等等。在最后之前不要想任何事情。最后，闭上眼睛给出一个分数。那个人会是一个多好的士兵？现在令我惊讶的是，那个直觉分数确实非常好。我的意思是，它和六个特质的平均值一样好。
And it's different, so it adds content. So having an intuition, if you delay it, it's quite good. The kicker of that story was that about 50 years later or so, I got a Nobel Prize for a short time, I was a celebrity in Israel. They took me to the army to my old base, and they explained how they were doing the interview because they were still using that system, essentially, with very little change.
而且它不同，所以它增加了内容。所以拥有直觉，如果你推迟它，它是相当不错的。那个故事的妙处在于大约50年后，我获得了诺贝尔奖，有一段时间，我在以色列是个名人。他们带我去了军队，去了我的老基地，他们解释了他们是如何进行面试的，因为他们基本上仍然在使用那个系统，几乎没有什么变化。
And then the commander was telling me, and then she said, and then we tell them, close your eyes. So that thing had lasted for 50 years. That is that expression. So what I love about that, it's not so much intuition versus bias, but it's more maybe by just delaying intuition, the intuition gets better. And of course, if you don't do the detailed analysis, you still have an intuition that feels
然后指挥官告诉我，然后她说，然后我们告诉他们，闭上眼睛。所以那件事持续了50年。这就是那个表达。所以我喜欢的是，与其说是直觉与偏见的对立，不如说可能是通过推迟直觉，直觉会变得更好。当然，如果你不做详细的分析，你仍然会有一种感觉
very powerful and your ignorance is sort of papered over by this tendency of the mind. You know, intuition is compelling as such. I mean, you know, we have the intuition almost by definition. We trust it. And so delaying this and remaining very close to facts, as you collect your separate dimensions, is really very useful. And it permits an intuition that is well informed. Because normally we form intuitions very quickly. And then we spend the rest of the time
非常强大的直觉，而你的无知被这种思维倾向所掩盖。你知道，直觉本身就是令人信服的。我的意思是，你知道，我们几乎根据定义就拥有直觉。我们信任它。所以推迟这一点，并在收集各个维度时保持非常接近事实，确实非常有用。它允许一种信息充分的直觉。因为通常我们很快就会形成直觉。然后我们花剩下的时间
confirming that YAM, the situation was right. That, by the way, is a thought. It's been studied that way, in interviews, people form impressions in the first minute or two, and they spend the rest of the time testing that they're right, and, of course, confirming that they're right. So, this was clearly an example of how you came up with a mechanism in some ways to overcome how the mind works. But on many, many other fronts, it seems like the biases errors that you've discovered, even yourself, you say that you don't necessarily, you're not the master of those biases after
确认那个直觉是对的。顺便说一句，这是一个想法。它以那种方式被研究过，在面试中，人们在第一两分钟内形成印象，然后他们花剩下的时间测试他们是对的，当然，确认他们是对的。所以，这显然是一个例子，说明你是如何想出一个机制在某些方面克服思维运作方式的。但在许多其他方面，似乎你发现的偏见错误，甚至你自己，你说你不一定，你在研究它们半个多世纪后，并不是这些偏见的主人。
studying them for more than half a century. Yeah, I mean, even myself. I mean, I'm considered one of the worst offenders on many of these mistakes. So, you know, I'm overconfident when I really preach against that and I make extreme predictions and I preach against that. But, you know, some people read thinking fast and slow in the hope that reading it will improve their minds. I wrote it and it didn't improve my mind. It's not those things that are deep and powerful and they're hard to change.
是的，我的意思是，甚至我自己。我的意思是，在这些错误中，我被认为是表现最差的人之一。所以，你知道，当我真的反对过度自信时，我却过度自信，我做出极端的预测，而我却反对这样做。但是，你知道，有些人读《思考，快与慢》是希望阅读它能改善他们的思维。我写了它，但它并没有改善我的思维。这些东西不是那种深刻而强大且难以改变的东西。
Danny yesterday was your 84th birthday. Happy birthday. You've studied a great number of different things over the years and you tell me that one of the things that you're actually interested in studying is the subject of misery, much more than happiness, you're fascinated by misery. Now of course I can just put this down to the pessimism that clearly you've demonstrated for a long time. But you actually say you can draw more specific conclusions and there are takeaways from studying misery than from studying happiness.
丹尼，昨天是你84岁生日。生日快乐。多年来你研究了大量不同的事物，你告诉我，你实际上感兴趣研究的事情之一是苦难的主题，远多于快乐，你对苦难着迷。现在当然，我可以把这归结为长期以来你表现出的悲观情绪。但你实际上说，与研究快乐相比，研究苦难可以得出更具体的结论，并且有更多的收获。
Yeah, I'm actually, you know, I contributed to what is called happiness research. But I'm really disturbed by it. And I'm disturbed by positive psychology. In part, because I think that making people happier, it could be important how to do. It may not be society's business to make people happier. But reducing suffering, that's something else.
是的，我实际上，你知道，我为所谓的快乐研究做出了贡献。但我对此感到不安。我对积极心理学感到不安。部分原因是，我认为让人们更快乐，这可能很重要，但如何做到这一点。让人们更快乐可能不是社会的职责。但减少痛苦，那是另一回事。
It's easy to agree that this is important. It's easy to agree that this is important. It's easy to agree that society should be involved. Furthermore, it's easier to measure a misery than to measure happiness. And what we can do about it is clear than what we can do to enhance happiness. So from all these points of view, I think that, and again, you know, it's a matter of a semantic luck. You know, we speak of length and not of shortness, and so we
很容易同意这很重要。很容易同意这很重要。很容易同意社会应该参与其中。此外，衡量苦难比衡量快乐更容易。而且我们能对此做些什么比我们能做些什么来增强快乐更清楚。所以从所有这些观点来看，我认为，再次，你知道，这是一个语义运气的问题。你知道，我们谈论长度而不是短度，所以我们
speak of happiness and not the other side of unhappiness. But if you focus on unhappiness and misery, you end up doing very different things, thinking very different thoughts and taking different actions, which I think we should do. So you've been a wonderful sport, Danny, and I'm really grateful for you for coming down, and I'm almost a little shame faced about doing what I'm about to do right now, which is I'm wondering if we can increase your happiness just a tad, but it might increase your misery by singing Happy birthday to you. You are one of hidden brands heroes and we feel that it's really appropriate to end with that. So on the count of three, happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you. Thank you.
谈论快乐而不是不快乐的另一面。但如果你专注于不快乐和苦难，你最终会做非常不同的事情，思考非常不同的想法并采取不同的行动，我认为我们应该这样做。所以你一直是一个很棒的人，丹尼，我真的很感谢你过来，我甚至对即将要做的事情感到有点羞愧，那就是我想知道我们是否可以通过为你唱生日快乐歌来增加你的一点点快乐，尽管这可能会增加你的苦难。你是Hidden Brain的英雄之一，我们觉得以这种方式结束真的很合适。所以数到三，祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐。谢谢。
Danny Coniman, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brains 100th episode. My pleasure. APPLAUSE This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Raina Cohen, Karam Gurghaleson, and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Renek Larr, Pat Shah, and Matthew Schwartz. Our engineers are Andy Huthur and Neil Tavolt. I'm Shankar Vedantum. See you next week. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
丹尼·卡尼曼，感谢你今天参加Hidden Brain的第100集节目。我的荣幸。掌声 本集Hidden Brain由Raina Cohen、Karam Gurghaleson制作，Tara Boyle编辑。我们的团队包括Jenny Schmidt、Renek Larr、Pat Shah和Matthew Schwartz。我们的工程师是Andy Huthur和Neil Tavolt。我是Shankar Vedantum。下周见。谢谢。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。